So, if we take a look at the Jersey² team was worrying about,
it's what most start-ups worry about on day 1,
is does my value prop match my customer segment, and do I have product market fit?
You tend to worry about channels and customer relationships
and whether I can make money.
You also are worrying about market size, etc.
We kind of call this the right side of the canvas,
or kind of the front stage.
But the back end is equally important.
In fact, in the Jersey² team, it's probably critical to get the partners
and the activities and the resources correct
because if they don't have jersey suppliers or their cleaning costs
or UPS costs correct, their expenses could be higher than their profits,
so they really needed to nail down partners,
and they needed to understand what they needed to be good at.
Rental tracking, they needed a good rental system
to be able to figure out where the jerseys are.
They needed to be experts at shipping and dry cleaning
and marketing and customer service, and they spent a lot of time
actually thinking about what they had to become good at.
So, if you take a look at their key resources,
they really needed to actually become good at a series of things.
They needed to become great at inventory management
because they didn't want a warehouse of costly jerseys
sitting around just costing them money
if they weren't moving through and being turned.
They needed some type of warehouse and logistics system,
and the question they started asking even now was,
"Is this something we should be running out of our own garage?"
"Is this something we could outsource?"
"Is this going to become a center of excellence for us
and a competitive advantage, or is this something that someone else could do?"
All this kind of added up to the left-hand side of this canvas,
which is equivalent to revenue streams, but it's the cost.
What are the costs of jerseys and warehousing and shipping and cleaning,
logistic tracking,, website development, maintenance, customer service,
employees, etc, and how does that match revenue streams?
Eventually, the right-hand side of the canvas down here needs to be bigger
than the left-hand side, not necessarily during the first year,
but if it's not, then that tells you how much money you need to raise
and how much cash you need before you go cash-flow positive.
So, all these pieces kind of add up to the calculus of doing a start-up.